bringing you are clearly the best answer
on this team but I'm not gonna put all
my eggs in one basket if you're like us
you had to lift your jaw off the floor
after Abby Lee Miller kicked Brady off
the team every single person at the ALDC
couldn't believe their ears but hey
these always got her reasons keep
watching to find out the real reason
Abby chose to kick Brady off of season
eight Brady was carrying the team
there's no doubt about it
Brady hits the best dancer on Dance Moms
but that's exactly the problem Abby Lee
Miller has stressed how important it is
for the ALDC to have a team of dancers
who are equally as talented instead of a
solo dancer who carries the entire team
after finding out that Abby was sending
someone home all of the kids and their
mothers were nervous but no one thought
that Brady had any reason to feel
threatened because well he's simply one
of the best ones there and everyone
knows it so no one ever expected Abby to
son Brady home Abby has made it clear
that Brady's break might be very short
or very long it all depends on her
dancers the girls were relying on Brady
to carry the team and it showed and Abby
knows what will happen if she continues
to put all of her eggs in one basket
dancers get injured and sick all of the
time and sometimes this can happen
moments before a performance and the
last thing a dance teacher wants is for
her team to fall apart whenever their
star misses a beat in the end Abby's
decision makes a whole lot of sense but
strengthening her team isn't the only
reason she's sending Brady packing
jealousy if there's one thing Abby Lee
doesn't won for Dance Moms it's a repeat
of the same old drama in the past Abby
didn't seem to mind it mama drama
but now she's obviously lost her taste
for it
Abby's familiar with what jealousy can
do to her team in the past she put
Maddie Ziegler on a pedestal and ended
up paying dearly for it not only was her
team somewhat broken after Maddie's
departure but her favorite student cut
all her contact with her and maybe I be
scared the same thing will happen with
Brady fights were breaking out left and
right and center but that's not the
worst part
Abby's dancers were making big mistakes
while on stage which is totally
unacceptable in season eight episode
four Lilliana missed her side Ariel
while dancing on stage and Abby pointed
it out afterward Lily was crying and
clearly shaken but she said something
that Abby didn't want to hear
she partially blamed her mistake on the
fact that Abby had said that she was
jealous of Brady before the show by now
we all know that Abby isn't a fan of
tears and seeing the mothers bicker over
her giving Brady special treatment was a
serious wake-up call after realizing
just how jealous everyone was a Brady
she decided that a recast was of utmost
importance if you can't take the heat
get out of the ALDC the girls may love
dancing with Brady but their mothers all
have something negative to say they
complain if their daughters aren't in
the spotlight and they get jealous when
someone else's kid is the star of the
show Brie's dance is the one that's most
ahead
great thanks Days having a boy on the
team is super advantageous but some moms
just aren't happy with their kid being
in the background which causes a lot of
friction stacy is constantly going at it
with Trisha and it makes everyone feel
uncomfortable to top it all off all the
Dance Moms are jealous of Brady and they
can't cope with him being treated
differently than everyone else
since Brady's usually on point Abby
doesn't have to yell at him during
rehearsals and that's something the
other moms love to talk about but all
this friction is only causing harm and
Abby wants to snuff out the fire before
someone gets burnt we totally get why
Abby Lee Miller chose to send Brady home
but was it really the right thing to do
in the end
Brady earned his spot and as
fighting to keep it since the very
beginning which isn't the case for every
dancer on the team fans are conflicted
about Abby's decision to send brady home
and some couldn't help but point out
that abby seemed a bit bitter about
kicking him off the show as well after
all he's obviously her favorite but
putting all her eggs in one basket isn't
an option anymore some fans think that
Brady's departure has everything to do
with his mother Trisha who isn't as
dramatic as the producers would want her
to be I might be back next week Michelle
guess what you may not in the end it
doesn't seem fair that someone as
talented as Brady has to go home because
he's better than everyone else but it
looks like he won't be the only one
going home Abby's been vocal about how
disappointed she is with her team no one
is carrying their own weight and
mistakes keep happening and most
surprisingly the team's been on a losing
streak many of us have been wondering if
Brady is going to come back to Dance
Moms but for now the dancers been put on
the back burner surprisingly though
Eliana walmsley will be joining the team
to temporarily replace Savannah but some
fans are convinced that she'll be taking
over Brady's spot for good on top of
that Cameron Smith is also rumoured to
be returning to the ALDC Abby wants a
team of champions and she's made it
clear that everyone is replaceable
Abby's learned from her past mistakes
and won't be repeating them anytime soon
still we can't help but feel bad for
Brady so do you guys think it's fair
that Brady was sent home despite being
the best dancer on the show sound off in
the comments section below for more
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows subscribe to the things and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching we'll catch you
next time
[Music]